we now come to the Urgent question
Joanna turret
to ask the Secretary of State for the
home Department if she will make a
statement on the policing of protests
during the coronation
Mr Speaker the coronation was a once in
a generation moment
a moment of national pride a moment when
the eyes of the world were upon us a
ceremony with roots over a millennium
old marking A Renewed dedication to
service by his majesty the king in this
new reign
Mr Speaker the coronation went smoothly
and without disruption I thank the
eleven and a half thousand police
officers on duty alongside six and a
half thousand military personnel and
many civilians
commissioner Mark Rowley today outlined
the intelligence picture in the hours
leading up to the coronation
intelligence picture included more than
one plot to cause severe disruption by
placing activated rape alarms in the
path of horses to induce a stampede and
a separate plot to douse participants in
the procession with paint this was the
context a once in a generation national
moment facing specific intelligence
threats about multiple well-organized
plots to disrupted
the police's Focus was rightly on
ensuring this momentous occasion passed
safely and without major disruption
that was successful all the plots to
disrupt the coronation were foiled by a
combination of intelligence work and
proactive Vigilant policing on the
ground
I would like to thank and congratulate
the police for this success
at the same time extensive wait wait for
it at the same time extensive planning
ensured protests could take place this
was also successful
hundreds of protesters exercised their
right to peaceful protest including a
large group numbering in the hundreds in
and around Trafalgar Square
now where the police reasonably believed
they had grounds for arrest they acted
the latest information is that 64
arrests were made I won't comment on
individual cases or specific decisions
but the arrests included a person wanted
for sexual offenses people equipped to
commit criminal damage with large
quantities of paint and arrests on
suspicion of conspiracy to cause public
nuisance often backed by intelligence
the Mets update last night included
regret to use their word that six people
arrested couldn't join the hundreds
protesting in Trafalgar Square and
nearby the Met has confirmed those six
people have now had their bail canceled
with no further action Mr Speaker the
police are operationally independent and
for the Met it is primarily for the
mayor of London to hold them to account
but let's be clear
at the weekend officers had to make
difficult judgments in fast time in a
highly pressured situation against the
threatening intelligence picture I thank
the police for doing that for delivering
a successful coronation and for enabling
safe peaceful protests
Chuck thank you Mr Speaker on Saturday
millions of people greatly enjoyed the
coronation ceremony others who wish to
see a republic chose to protest
peacefully as is their right in a
Democratic Society protests in Glasgow
and Edinburgh went off without incident
however in London protesters who had
gone to considerable lengths to liaise
with the Metropolitan Police in advance
of their protests and to clear both the
nature and the location of the protest
were detained searched arrested and held
in the cells from 7am till after 11 pm
all six of those arrested have now
received letter saying there'll be no
further action taken against them there
were a number of other arrests of
concern but because there's no legal
proceedings in respect of the six and
therefore re no reason for Parliament
not to begin today to address what
happened to them I'm going to focus on
them Graham Smith the leader of the
group Republic tells me that the
arresting police showed absolutely no
interest in contacting the liaison team
and seemed focused on luggage straps
holding placards together which they
said bed might be used to lock on the
joint committee on human rights has
repeatedly stressed that public
authorities including the police are
under a negative obligation not to not
to interfere with the right to protest
unlawfully and a positive obligation to
facilitate peaceful protest so why did
police arrest protesters who'd gone to
Such Great Lengths to clear their
protest in advance and why did they do
so on grounds which they now admit are
not sufficient to charge them and
without following up with the liaison
team what do citizens need to do now to
clear a protest in advance on the BBC
Radio 4 today programs sir Peter fahi
the former Chief Constable of Greater
Manchester police said what had happened
has to be seen in the context of media
political and public pressure on the
police he referred to what he called
quotes some pretty direct and personal
feedback brought to bear on Sir Mark
Rowley before the home Affairs select
committee on 26 April by The Honorable
member for Ashfield and I have notified
him that I had mentioned him his Mr
Speaker so was political pressure
brought to bear on the police
sir Peter also said that the legislation
the public order bill and the policing
Act is very purely defined and far too
broad and that is what opposition MPS
warned off particularly like regarding
offenses like locking on so will you
reviewed the legislation and set up an
inquiry into what happened to these six
citizens on Saturday
uh thank you Mr Speaker and I thank the
honorable and uh learned member for her
question I have the greatest
um respect for her and will take her
questions uh seriously she asked about
uh pressure the police are of course
operationally uh independent and make
these decisions independently of
government uh government ministers did
receive a briefing particularly as the
intelligence picture escalated in the 24
hours uh prior to the event but the
mayor of London also received briefings
as I understand did the shadow Home
Secretary
um I believe on Friday so there was
nothing out of the ordinary in ministers
receiving uh briefings not least because
there is a need to coordinate between
the police and other agencies
um both security agencies and other
civilian agencies as well in terms of
legislation uh this house has just
debated and scrutinized at some length
the legislation and there is no plans to
change that in relation to
um the six people who were arrested in
the question of protest more generally I
will just repeat the point Mr Speaker I
made in my initial answer that I think
hundreds of people did exercise their
peaceful right to protest it was done as
The Honorable and learned lady said
following engagement with the Republic
protest group in advance and the fact
that hundreds of people were able to
peacefully protest I think is Testament
to the rights of peaceful protest in
relation to those six people I don't
want to get into the um details of that
because frankly neither She nor I have
all the facts but clearly at the point
the arrest was made the police
reasonably believed there were grounds
to do so but I emphasize again for
hundreds I think several hundreds of
people on that day they were able to
peacefully protest as is their absolute
right
David Davis
thank you Mr Speaker nobody should
question that this was a difficult time
for the Metropolitan Police a difficult
task to achieve and nobody should
question that in the large respect They
carried it out brilliantly and gave us a
marvelous occasion uh this weekend
that being said within one week of the
public order Bill entering the law and
in its first serious use we end up with
the head of the Met having to apologize
to people who are wrongfully arrested
in the event that let us say the uh home
Affairs select committee reviews this
matter and comes back with
recommendations as to how we change
guidelines and maybe laws will the home
office take it on board
well I would just um cautioned my right
honorable friend against asserting these
people were wrongfully arrested that is
uh not an assertion that has been that
is that is a legal that is a legal
threshold and I don't think it's been
established that that legal threshold
has been has been met I would also in
terms of testing this legislation I
would also um just draw The house's
attention to the fact this was a once in
a lifetime event and it took place
against an intelligence backdrop which
suggested there were multiple
well-organized plots to cause very
serious disruption which if they had
proceeded uh would have been taken very
seriously by this house and been seen
around the world so I don't think one
can infer from what happened at the
weekend that the recently passed
legislation
um is defective
Sarah Jones
thank you Mr Speaker the coronation of
King Charles III involved the largest
police effort ever undertaken I want to
thank the thousands of police officers
who ensured so many people were able to
enjoy such a historic occasion without
incident
rightly in our democracy those police
had operational responsibility and had
to take decisions at PACE and under
pressure
and rightly in our democracy we also
have scrutiny and accountability where
problems arise
hundreds of people who chose to do so
were able to protest and as the minister
stated some plans to disrupt were foiled
but serious concerns have been raised
about some of the arrests the six people
from Republic were arrested under new
powers in the public order act being
equipped for locking on which came into
Force two days before the coronation
they have now been released with no
further action and the Met has expressed
regret
Mr Speaker the minister knows that I
have warned him and his colleagues
repeatedly that this new power means
that people might be arrested for the
wrong thing carrying a bike lock in
their bag or as happened in this case
some luggage straps
many former police officers have warned
that these Powers put the police in a
difficult position and risk undermining
the notion of policing by consent
these arrests raise questions that we do
want answers to why the arresting
officers didn't know or take account
that Republic had been working with the
police or why they were held for 16
hours
does the minister support the review by
the mayor of London so Parliament can
see lessons to be learned and on the new
public order Powers will he ask the
inspector and the College of policing to
Monitor and review them and report back
to Parliament and will he support the
recommendations in the inspectors report
for more specific training for our
officers on public order
this weekend was a celebration and one
that could not have happened without the
dedication of our Police Service but
just as important to our British
democracy as our constitutional monarchy
is our historic model of policing by
consent trust and our freedom to
peacefully protest it is our job as
members of parliament to come up with
laws that solve problems not create them
so I urge the minister opposite to learn
the lessons and take responsibility for
protecting that careful balance between
the police and the people
yeah
well look I mean I think it is important
to maintain the balance as the shadow
Minister sets out but as I pointed out
in my opening response and my subsequent
one to the uh honorable member uh
opposite the right to protest was for
those hundreds of people protected the
protests did happen and indeed there is
no question in principle or in any
legislation that the right to peaceful
protest is sacrosanct we have of course
in recent months seen that right for
peace to peaceful protest being
stretched into acts that are
deliberately disruptive where people
have sought to close down the M25
they've sought to close down the Streets
of London uh not so much as an act of
protest but to deliberately
inconvenience the public and that is
where we draw the line at the weekend
that is broadly the same test that was
being applied peaceful protests of
course absolutely fine activity that was
designed to seriously disrupt the
coronation including potentially causing
a stampede of horses or covering the
ceremonial procession in paint was not
acceptable the police had to make
difficult judgment this is a unique
situation I think it probably can agree
it is pretty pretty unique that to make
very difficult decisions in very fast
time against an extremely threatening
intelligence picture uh often the facts
were at the time unclear that is very
difficult I think all of us here should
just accept those are difficult
decisions and I think the police
obviously it's for them to answer
operationally um but they if they were
here would say they acted lawfully uh to
the best of their reasonable belief um
at the time but I do want to put on
record the right to peaceful protest is
sacrosanct and I'm sure no one in this
house on either side would ever seek to
undermine it
I clear this thank you very much Mr
Speaker would the minister agree with me
that as a matter of law
the fact of the matter is that the
police are entirely within their rights
to arrest individuals to prevent a crime
it happens somewhere in the country
pretty much every day they obviously do
not have to wait until a crime is
actually committed the active offense is
committed before acting if they knew an
armed robbery was about to take place
from intelligence received they don't
have to wait until that armed robbery is
taking place before acting and the same
applies here does the minister agree
with me that the police did an excellent
job in very difficult circumstances and
this is a government that supports the
police we will leave the opposition
parties to support those who do not
follow the law yeah and the fact of the
matter is in extremely difficult
circumstances they did a good job and
just remind you you're not at the bar
now you've got shots and questions
look I thank my right honorable and
learned friend for his question uh yes I
do agree the police did a good job in
what were very difficult fast-moving
circumstances where judgments were
inevitably difficult it is easy to
criticize after the event but I think
the police did a good job in what we're
extremely trying and difficult
circumstances SMP spokesperson thank you
very much Mr Speaker the UN commissioner
for human rights has said the public
order Act is incompatible with the right
to freedom of expression peaceful
assembly and Association is deeply
disappointing to hear labor and the
conservatives now both support wedded to
this legislation that undermines our
right to protest your aim Smith the CEO
of Republic has said that these arrests
are a direct attack in our democracy and
the fundamental rights of every person
in the country he further says the right
to protest peacefully in the UK no
longer exists instead we have a freedom
to protest that is contingent in the
political decisions made by ministers
and Senior police officers that is
entirely unacceptable and in Reading
it's a mark rowley's statement that he
has put out he says having review the
evidence and potential lines of inquiry
we do not judge that we'll be able to
prove communal attempt beyond all
reasonable doubts so these arrests were
not necessary and further Sir Mark Riley
says he supports the officer's actions
in this unique fast-moving operational
context which means that if similar
circumstances occurred there is no
certainty that this would not just
happen again so will the the minister uh
tell me further what protections people
can expect when they're in good faith
engage with authorities before protest
to prevent this kind of thing happening
to find it happen again and is he
concerned that journalists a journalist
was amongst those arrested
well it is entirely inaccurate to say
the right to protest does not exist as I
pointed out hundreds and hundreds of
people did peacefully and lawfully
protest on Coronation Day they did so
unmolested and unimpeded which I think
goes to show this idea that the right to
protest doesn't exist uh it doesn't
exist anymore it's absolute nonsense
what does not exist is the right to
cause uh disruption to other members of
society that is what that is what our
laws seek to prevent and in relation to
uh the Human Rights Act and particularly
articles 10 and 11 of the echr
um you know there's been the the recent
public order act had a section 19 1A
statement on the front of it uh saying
that legal analysis finds it is
compatible and if the honorable lady
studies articles 10 and 11 and
particularly the second paragraphs of
those she will see they are balanced
they are balanced rights balanced with
uh the the qualified rights which are
able to be balanced against the right of
democratically elected legislators to
legislate to prevent criminal activity
including disruption
you very much indeed Mr Speaker would my
item of a friend agree with me that the
Metropolitan Police did a great job here
they took the necessary action to
protect the public during a unique State
event and not one word but we've heard
opposite or anything's going to come
we'll be able to give any evidence to
the country in respect to that it is
reassuring that for once the
Metropolitan Police acts on the side of
the hard work in public who want to have
your
enjoy events rather than being the
victims of left-wing protest groups
[Music]
I agree with my normal friend
coach chair of the select committed
named Daniel Johnson speaker can I add
my thanks to those involved in the
arrangements for the coronation and
keeping the public safe however I think
the home Affairs select committee will
no doubt want to look at the policing of
protests at the coronation and in
particular the specific Provisions in
the public order act brought in just
last week and used to arrest members of
republic
and we've heard a lot about operational
Independence of the police this
afternoon so can the minister just
explain why the home offices police
Powers unit on the 27th of April sent an
official letter to Republic ahead of the
coronation now of course Republic have
no history of locking on
I just want to know how many other
organizations uh receive these letters
what other groups receive them and on
what basis they were sent these letters
and whether this practice will now be
the norm for the home office
Melissa and well any such letters um I
don't believe were sent in my name so I
can't comment on uh who may have
received them I suspect although I'm not
certain
um that these related to clarifying the
new statutory Provisions that were
recently brought into effect through the
public order act uh 2023 the operational
Independence of the police is important
because Parliament legislates and it is
then for the police to apply those laws
without fear uh or favor and they did so
on this occasion
it's been a misunderstanding clearly
despite the police doing a brilliant job
that's why there's been an apology but
wouldn't the minister expect that
misunderstanding to have been resolved
well within the 16 hours for which the
six were
incarcerated uh and surely there should
be some questions asked about that
yeah well again um exactly uh what
happened is an operational matter for
the police clearly on that day uh
Saturday just gone uh the police had a
lot going on in central London policing
the largest public event that we have
ever had in our country's um history I
don't know and in fact no member of this
house knows or can know precisely what
inquiries were being undertaken uh while
the decision ultimately to release those
individuals was taken but of course
there are uh complaint processes
available uh if any individual member of
the public wants to follow them uh
they're available to anyone uh who is
arrested or indeed who encounters the
police and if someone feels the police
have behaved in a particular situation
unreasonably but are able to use those
complaint procedures Richard Berger
thank you Mr Speaker
isn't it the case that the arrests we
saw of peaceful protesters at the
weekend weren't an aberration but were
exactly what the public order acts is
designed to do to clamp down on
legitimate peaceful protest which should
be a basic Democratic rights in this
country
no that is not the purpose of the public
order act the public order Act is
designed to prevent people deliberately
disrupting the daily lives of their
fellow citizens which we have seen with
locking on on public highways causing
enormous traffic jams stopping people
getting to hospital stopping people
getting their children to school people
being unable to get to work we've seen
10 mile tailbacks on the M25 and we had
specific intelligence that people
planned to disrupt the coronation by
creating a stampede of horses and
covering the ceremonial procession in
paint the public order act 2023 is
designed to stop that kind of disruption
while of course allowing peaceful
protest that is its purpose
we'll be French Mr Speaker and I feel
given some of the heat of the debate I
must add that as a greater London MP
it's complete and utter nonsense that
you can no longer peacefully protest in
London I myself attended my first ever
protest a couple weeks ago where I was
protesting against the mayor of London's
disgraceful Euless and we were left to
peacefully protest but does my honorable
friend agree that the police and our
Armed Forces those eleven and a half
thousand police officers and Armed
Forces did an excellent job over the
weekends to police and keep the public
safe during the Fantastic coronation
celebrations well any mannerable friend
puts it very well I join him by the way
in opposing uh silicon's appalling you
less idea and but on the on the
coronation police and yes they did a
great job I know there were almost 30
000 officers deployed at one time or
another during the relevant period
between the Met Force area and Thames
Valley for the Windsor uh concert the
following day there were I think eleven
and a half thousand deployed on the day
of the coronation itself in addition to
six and a half thousand Armed Forces
Personnel we also by the way had 320 12
protected people coming into the country
from around the world and we had I think
almost a thousand close protection
officers deployed as well all of those
officers did a fantastic job in what was
I think a moment of national pride for
all of us I was just gone Mike yeah Mr
Speaker hey can I just say to the
policing Minister I'm a little bit
surprised that he should apparently
accept without question the proposition
the the Metropolitan Police now
apologizes to people who have been
lawfully arrested even by his standards
that's something of a novel departure
but the public order act has given
police officers very Broad and sweeping
Powers which in turn requires the police
to exercise discretion and judgment with
no context or guidelines and the
consequence if there is no change to
this legislation things like this will
keep happening there should have been
better pre-legislative scrutiny of this
act there wasn't will he no commit to
giving us Post legislatures
well I mean of course many pieces of
legislation
um require on the ground interpretation
whether by the police or subsequently uh
by the courts in case law indeed the
precise definitions contained in this
new piece of legislation the public
order act 2023 include things like much
more precise definitions of what
constitutes serious disruption which was
previously extremely ambiguous and that
Clarity is something which the police
and others
um had called for uh in terms of
scrutiny obviously the house is uh
welcome to conduct scrutiny uh whenever
it wants I think as a matter of standard
new bits of legislation are subject to
post alleged scrutiny
um sometime later but actually in many
areas this new Act of parliament
recently uh taken effect or recently
gained Royal Ascent provides additional
specificity Clarity and precision that
was previously lacking
the minister said rightly that hundreds
of people protested against the once in
a generation coronation hundreds of
thousands of people were present to
actually celebrate the coronation while
millions in the United Kingdom and
around the world watched it I'm getting
pretty fed up actually with the police
apologizing all the time I can say the
ordinary police officers doing a decent
job as they did on Saturday find their
morale is at Rock Bottom when they're
given the instruction we will deal
robustly with anyone intent on
undermining the celebration which came
from the Met police on the 3rd of May
and then finding that someone is
apologizing for them doing just that
I think the Metropolitan Police
Commissioner had an article in today's
evening standard which very robustly uh
sets out the background and defends the
police's approach to the coronation in
fact if any member of the House has not
yet read that evening standard article I
think it was published earlier today and
I'd strongly recommend members on both
sides uh to read it I think uh the
comment he refers to specifically was an
expression of regret that those six
people were unable to join the hundreds
of others who were peacefully protesting
now the hundreds of others were
exercising their right to peaceful
protest as they are perfectly entitled
to do but it is worth mentioning in
passing as my honorable friend has just
done they were in a tiny tiny tiny
minority but that does not in any way
undermine their right to protest if they
choose to five looks Mr Speaker I think
it looks terribly obvious to anyone that
looks at this that if you take a piece
of draconian legislation like the public
order bill
pass it through rush it through this
place whether via an unelected Head of
State who gave it consent hand it to a
failing institution like the
Metropolitan Police who then decapitate
the leadership of the Republican protest
move and what do you expect this piece
of legislation is doing exactly what it
says on the tin it's stopping peaceful
protest
that is absolute nonsense this
legislation is preventing disruption to
the lives of our fellow citizens I
wholly repudiate the suggestion it was
rushed through those extensive ping pong
which I do not recall the honorable
gentleman uh turning up to if he was so
concerned about about scrutiny and as
for his comment about the process for a
bill gaining Royal Ascent I will not
dignify that with a response
you Mr Speaker
are into this I think the police did a
fantastic job yeah yeah yeah I think
they took actions Under Pressure they
had to make decisions quickly to ensure
that a great National event went ahead
without without any kind of negative
event I'm very glad that happened does
the minister agree
um share with me some of the concerns
that some of the just stop all process
they might have found a bit of a
loophole in the public order act and
actually think they can get away with
slow marching will the minister assure
me this isn't the case and that we don't
continue to see just up all protests
called havoc in our towns
and well just stop oil uh have adapted
their tactics since they
um blocked the M25 back in I think
November and caused 10 Mile tailbacks uh
following which a number of arrests were
made uh some of whom were in fact then
remanded into uh custody they have now
changed their tactics with these uh slow
walking uh tactics but the police are
now uh applying cumulative disruption
tests to that uh using section 12 of the
1986 public order act and they are
making notices under that act and recent
disruptions in the last sort of 10 to 14
uh days have seen the roads cleared uh
typically within less than 10 minutes
which I'm sure uh londoners my
constituents and others will uh welcome
very strongly Lucas
Mr Speaker the minister just said that
the right to peaceful protest is
sacrosanct and that no one would seek to
undermine it but I would put it to him
that that is exactly and precisely what
his government has just done ministers
are criminalizing protest and just
because some people were allowed to go
ahead and protest does not mitigate
against the fact that a number of them
were not and if I could just correct the
minister those who were arrested and
kept uh in were not causing an
obstruction which is presumably exactly
why the police then went to apologize to
them afterwards so doesn't this show
that the powers the government has
handed to the police are dangerously
broad liable to gross misuse as many of
us have pointed out and can I urge him
again to urgently review this piece of
legislation
no I don't accept that analysis the
powers are designed to prevent uh
prevent disruption uh where it might
occur or where it is occurring that
includes things like locking on which we
have seen uh cause huge disruption on
the Streets of London uh the law allows
peaceful protest where it's not
disruptive where people do not plan to
cause disruption and that is why
hundreds and hundreds of people will be
a tiny minority of the total were able
to peacefully protest where someone is
preparing to commit or is committing a
criminal offense like disrupting A
procession it is reasonable for the
police to act
Joe McDonald
as the secretary of the Nega
parliamentary group throughout the
passage of the public order legislation
I I asked for and was given by ministers
assurances that this legislation would
not impede upon journalistic freedoms
and yet on Saturday we saw at least one
journalist stopped in search nothing
found handcuffed his credentials torn
off him and then detained for 16 hours a
member of back to a professional
filmmaker could I ask the minister now
to investigate why the assurances this
house was given on media Freedom were
not adhered to
the new bill uh does contain a specific
clause which was I think added during
its passage protecting journalistic uh
freedoms I think if there is a and in
fact uh there was an incident in
Hertfordshire a few months ago I think
it was in November uh when a journalist
was was incorrectly arrested in the
relevant uh police force Hertfordshire
in that case uh apologize subsequently
the government did then legislate uh in
the recent bill as I say there is a
specific Clause protecting journalistic
Freedom
um I don't want to comment on an
individual operational matter not least
because neither he nor I have the full
facts but as I said already there is a
complaints process and if an individual
or others feel they weren't fairly or
properly treated they do have a
complaints process they can go through
but Parliament has made this view clear
on the Donald
does the
Minister agree with the former greater
Manchester police chief Sophia fahi who
has extensive experience of public order
policing who previously described the
public hard rock as purely defined and
far too broad and who added this weekend
that we are now seeing the consequences
of that
no I don't agree and I've already
explained why
thank you
Mr
s being able to protest as evidence that
our right to protest isn't undermined
but when people can be preemptively
arrested on the flimsiest of pretenses
and
then be thrown in a police cell for the
best part of 24 hours how can he say how
can he reassure people who are attending
a protest or even walking near a protest
that the same thing won't happen to them
how can he claim that our right to
protest isn't being undermined by his
government
well I've mentioned the echr
compatibility particularly in relation
to articles uh 10 and 11. before the
police can arrest anyone they do have to
have a reasonable grounds for suspicion
the defense has been committed obviously
individual operational decisions in this
case relating to six people uh something
that can be looked into uh subsequently
if that is if that is necessary uh but
the the bill itself the public order
bill has passed by parliament does
nothing to criminalize uh lawful
protests and as I've said hundreds and
hundreds of people uh did exercise
exactly that right although they were in
a tiny minority just in Marvels thank
you Mr Speaker there's no doubt the
police have a difficult job to do making
Swift on the ground judgments but I
think that their job is made harder when
they don't act in a consistent manner
now I I've had an eyewitness account
that's a a protester was allowed to go
in it's amongst the Republicans for
about 10 minutes on challenge jostling
them acting in a provocative manner
right in front of the police before the
police actually to be there's no doubt
that was disruption but the police
didn't act for quite a long time there
so does he agree that actually that sort
of thing creates the impression that
some types of protests are more equal
than others yeah I haven't heard that
particular account before and so I don't
think it's really appropriate to comment
on something I've just heard about
across the floor of the chamber um but
I've already drawn The house's attention
to the procedures that are available to
members of the public and but I do
appreciate his opening comment that the
police did have a very difficult job
they were under enormous uh pressure
they were dealing with a number of
intelligence threats that I outlined at
the beginning of my uh response things
were moving very quickly often the
picture was confusing
um and things had to be done in often in
a in a rush so I do appreciate his
acknowledgment of a very difficult job
the police had to do but I think they
Rose to the occasion when did Jim
speaker now I voted against this bill
and legislative at every stage but as a
former police officer from Bill
committee stage onwards I highlighted
training the capacity and capability of
police officers in to be able to
exercise their powers so that those
Dynamic pressures that the minister just
referred to can actually be dealt with
appropriately so can the minister advise
how many officers were trained in
relation to this legislation uh prior to
to attending at the coronation on
Tuesday how many of them at what rank
and what does the training consist of
well obviously many officers do have a
specialist public order training the
overall uh gold Commander for the event
um is the modern Metropolitan police's
most experienced public order uh
commanders at the rank of at the rank of
Commander many officers have had uh
specialist uh public order training as I
say in the course of their career and
but it is important to make sure that
particularly as legislation changes the
training
the training keeps up keeps up with it
and I know the College of policing and
others will be issuing the relevant
guidance to make sure that is addressed
thank you Mr
the minister agree with me that the
Metropolitan Police says a mission of
regret regarding their arrest of six
anti-monarchy protesters this weekend is
an admission of guilt and does he accept
that this is a chilling violation of
basic Democratic rights and demonstrates
beyond a shadow of a doubt that the
public order act should be immediately
repealed
no I don't agree
Kirsten Oswald much Mr Speaker I think
that the minister has a real brass neck
the the story government brought in this
most
relation and then he he's in here
telling us that the police are
operationally independent of the
government as if it's absolutely nothing
to do with their actions the human Human
Rights Watch have said that what we saw
was something that you'd expect to see
in Moscow not London and I wonder if he
would agree with me that given the only
reportedly six percent of those who were
arrested for protesting against the
coronation were actually charged with
anything at all that this new
legislation is absolutely nothing but an
advert for how to impede people's right
to protest well I must say with great
respect I think that is nonsense and
comparing the policing of the coronation
with uh Putin's Moscow or Putin's Russia
where opposition figures are
incarcerated uh people like Alexis
navalny in prison uh suffering the most
appalling and inhumane treatment I think
it's frankly a bit of an insult to the
appalling treatment they are risk they
are suffering to in any way compare what
is happening there to the policing of
the coronation I don't think it is at
all respectful to those being oppressed
in Russia at all and you know in terms
of peaceful protest hundreds of people
uh did peacefully protest uh against the
monarchy it was a tiny minority but they
did protest the police only made those
array of 64 arrests in total where they
they had reasonable grounds to believe a
criminal offense had been committed or
was in preparation and if anyone feels
that the arrest they experienced wasn't
proper or appropriate there are
mechanisms they can use to complain and
to seek redress
her a buck
I appreciate this was an exceptionally
challenging weekend for the police but
I'm particularly concerned about the
arrested Detention of members of the
Westminster night Stars team who were
volunteers out in central London helping
to keep people safe now communication
between local authorities and the police
other agencies is absolutely critical so
can the minister assure me that he will
find out what happened what went wrong
in this communication and to be sure
that lessons are learned to make sure
that when volunteers were out supporting
the police in their work they do not get
arrested because of a breakdown in such
communication Minister and yes I think
that is a matter which first of all I
agree with her that the communication
between local authorities and police is
very important and that join up needs to
happen I think the question she has
asked is probably best directed via the
police and crime commissioner for the
mayor of London who I'm sure will be
happy to take up the query
Andy Slaughter thank you Mr Speaker no
one wished the new commissioner of the
Met success more than London MPS whose
constituents had suffered from a catalog
of institutional harm under his
predecessors but his statement in the
standard today is is political summer
school team will start to finish
including justifying arrests because
celebrating crowds were applauding and
cheering them isn't this a direct result
of the undue pressure put on the
commissioner by conservative party that
increasingly picks and chooses when it
follows the rule of law
Minister well I don't accept that I've
already pointed out the operational
Independence of the police and I've also
said that briefings by the met on the
coronation were received not just by
home office ministers but also by the
shadow Home Secretary and by the mayor
of London all of which was completely
proper Jeremy Corbin thank you Mr
Speaker the whole world could see on
Saturday the effects of this public
order legislation on policing trying to
prevent legitimate peaceful protests in
a democracy Willy reply in a considered
and reasonable way of an undertaking to
undertake a full review of the
operations of the public order Bill thus
far on preventing peaceful protest in
this country as an example of how
democracy is prepared to admit it's got
something wrong and is prepared to
change it
no what we saw on Saturday was the
police doing their best in very
difficult and challenging circumstances
to prevent disruption occurring while
allowing and facilitating peaceful
protest which indeed went ahead and
happened
littlest Chapman
Mr Speaker there's our own law in
Scotland if we are the best fishing is
carried out when it's done with the
concern of the public uh what is it
about admit that said when it comes to
public events the policing is
heavy-handed and often completely wrong
in its tones did the minister agree with
me that when such approaches is becomes
a part of the the pleasing approach
does that not under my public confidence
in the police itself I'm really review
originally basic training needs are the
met and there's a government there's
government dictate through the public
order Bill does that not get in the way
of good policing
look I mean training is very important
as his honorable uh friend mentioned a
little while uh ago and but once again
you know I don't think uh what we saw
was an unreasonable uh or indeed any
trampling on the right to protest we saw
hundreds of people exercising their
right to protest but I would also just
urge the house
um to keep in mind this was a unique
event it's a Once in a generation event
the art the eyes of the world were upon
us there were numerous uh intelligence
reports that I was briefed on about the
shadow Home Secretary was briefed on as
well indicating well-developed plots to
disrupt the coronation and the policing
response to this needs to be considered
in that context that's Winter thank you
Mr Speaker follow the arrests of
peaceful pro-democracy campaigners on
the route of the coronation on Saturday
the security ministers claim that the
weekend would and I quote showcase our
Liberty has fallen flat can the minister
please explain why he was the home
office and not the Metropolitan Police
who wrote or protest groups have
referred to as intimidatory letters
about the public order powers and can he
please provide a comprehensive
explanation as to why journalists are
now being arrested and when section 17
of the public order act prohibits this
yeah on the question uh of the letters
as I said earlier um those were not sent
as far as I can recall uh in in my name
uh they may well have been uh attempting
to be helpful by clarifying recently
enacted legislation which some groups
may not have been familiar with and it's
not unreasonable to try and make sure
relevant parties do know when the Law
changes uh in relation to journalistic
Freedom as she says uh this house and
the government supported by the
government voted to particularly and
specifically uh protect uh journalists
and that is the right thing to do if
anyone feels that hasn't been properly
implemented there are complaints
procedures available
there's a Cooper the speaker amongst
those arrested on Saturday was rich
felgate a documentary filmmaker who
identified himself as a journalist
claims that a police officer ripped off
his press credentials before he was then
arrested and detained the minister will
know that rich was one of four
journalists and filmmakers who were
arrested and detained in or near my
constituency in Hertfordshire last
November It is incomprehensible to me
that after the outcry last November
police forces can still keep getting the
basics wrong when it comes to protecting
the freedom of the press and the right
of journalists to do their jobs so will
the minister look again at this
legislation and will he please consider
again the proposal for a statutory Duty
on police to facilitate peaceful
protests and a proposal for a code of
conduct so the police and protesters
know where they stand well as I said two
or three times already the new public
order act does contain a clause
ignorable member opposite uh suggested a
moment ago it was Clause 17 which
specifically protects journalists uh
Freedom if there are and that of course
followed the incident in Hertfordshire
it was after the incident in
Hertfordshire if there are particular
examples particular individual cases
where the new law and indeed The Wider
echr right and common law right uh for
uh journalists is not being applied
there are complaints mechanisms but this
house supported by the government has
legislated specifically to protect
journalistic freedoms Hillary pen thank
you very much indeed Madam Deputy
speaker given what happened to these six
individuals on Saturday who were clearly
not involved in any plot to use rape
alarms or paint to disrupt the
coronation otherwise why the police
apologized to them what confidence can
the organizers of any future protests
have that what they have been told in
advanced planning meetings with the
police will actually be capable of being
reliable on the day well I I believe
again without needing to go into too
many specifics I believe uh the police's
assessment at the time didn't relate in
this particular case to rape alarms or
the paint but to locking on equipment
The Honorable member opposite says it is
clear but of course many things are
clear with hindsight things are
sometimes less clear In the Heat of a
live operation in terms of of assurance
around the right to protest you know
there the public order act does not in
any way infringer undermine the right to
protest and indeed we saw on Saturday a
quite a reasonable sized a few hundred
people uh protesting at the coronation
event without any impediment and we see
just stop oil protesters these days
protesting on an almost daily basis so
there is evidence in front of us showing
us how the right to protest unfolds on a
near daily basis Brendan O'Hara
on Saturday we saw metropolitan police
officers pre-arresting people whose only
offense was to want an elected head of
state despite their planned peaceful
protest being reauthorized UK citizens
who had committed no crime whatsoever
were taken off the streets and detained
simply because of the political beliefs
but isn't this exactly how this
anti-democratic Draconian authoritarian
piece of legislation was designed to
work and isn't it proof Minister that
this is what makes this legislation so
dangerously wrong minister no the
legislation does not in any way
criminalize or prevent protests we see
protests happening on a daily basis
including on Saturday what the
legislation does is enables the police
to prevent disruption they need to have
a reasonable belief in order to do that
if anyone feels that in this very small
minority of cases tiny minority of cases
those Powers were misapplied then there
are complaints uh procedures but the
vast vast vast majority of people
wishing to protest on Saturday did so
Deputy speaker can the minister confirm
whether the right to peaceful protest
only applies if the individual's views
chime with the government's own
I mean I'm not really sure that question
merits an answer and
translation is clearly uh politics
agnostic and it's for the police to
apply it without fear or favor
Mick Whitley
does the minister accept that the
troubling scenes witnessed during the
coronation vindicate that those of us on
this side of the house who own the
government's new anti-process laws would
be used to stifle descents and limit
freedom of expression and will he will
he accept that we are to protect the
most fundamental rights of three speech
than the public order bill must be
scrapped in the sincerity no as I said
repeatedly the public order act and
Associated legislation is designed to
prevent disruption to our fellow
citizens day-to-day lives while enabling
peaceful protest
Martin Dr Hughes let me congratulate
Edinburgh the member for Edinburgh
Southwest for actually gaining that
urgent question today modern Deputy
speaker uh the seemingly random nature
with which the Metropolitan Police can
apply the law only to fully exonerate
those arrested soon after is itself Akin
something one might see in an illegal
democracy like Hungary or turkey and all
this just a week after the security
minister themselves stood it the
dispatch walks there and said that the
coronation was a chance to Showcase her
Liberty so does the minister agree with
their colleague are these arrests a
Showcase of British Liberty
Minister I think the fact that hundreds
of people protested against the monarchy
albeit they were a tiny tiny minority of
the crowds demonstrates the right to
protest is unfettered the fact that I
suspect as we speak their adjustable
protesters somewhere in London uh no
doubt uh up to their protesting
activities uh as we have this discussion
uh here in Parliament so I think the
right to protest is sacrosanct it is
protected not least by the echr but also
by our domestic legislation that is
something we should all be pleased about
Deputy speaker the minister has
repeatedly told us today that there was
evidence of in his words a
well-developed plot to misuse activated
rape alarms in a way that would clearly
have been criminally Reckless and which
no one could condone given that that
plot was so well developed and with the
exception of the three night Stars
volunteers have been referred to already
can Minister tell us of all the people
arrested how many of them were founded
in possession of rape alarms how many of
them have been charged with intent to
use those rape alarms to criminal
purposes how many rape alarms have been
seized on Saturday and it answered to
all of those questions is no or next to
nil will the minister accept that in
this case the police intelligence was
badly and dangerously misinformed
no but I think there is an update on all
of the arrests on the Metropolitan
police's uh website which will provide
some of the information The Honorable
gentleman uh asks for some arrests were
made on the ceremonial close to the
ceremonial footprint including uh people
that had large quantities of paint other
arrests were made at locations away from
the ceremonial footprint and what might
be described as a safe house the
briefings that certainly I received from
the Met the night before and I believe
the mayor of London received and
possibly the shadow Home Secretary as
well I'm not sure indicated uh multiple
well-developed and credible plots to
materially disrupt the coronation and I
think it is greatly to the Metropolitan
police's credit that they prevented
those from unfolding
speaker
participating as I have an uh and and
put us across Northern all peaceful
protests and the politics of Northern
Ireland I think I recognize the
government is trying to ensure that
peaceful protests can take place the
coronation weekend has been a globally
celebrated event on something that the
United Kingdom will look back over many
years to to come with pride and the 64
arrests that were made were in the
lesson to I understand intelligence that
suggested that there would be deliberate
attempts to cause nuisance and
coronation day well the minister join me
into thanking the Met police or as
opposed to critiquing them for carrying
out their duties in a swift manner to
enable people to celebrate the
coronation of as Majesty the king and
peace and without disruption
yes I would I would join my honorable
friend in thanking the police and the
Armed Forces personnel and the civilians
involved in laying on the coronation for
a successful and ultimately peaceful
event despite the plots that were
uncovered in advance I'd like to you
know um also thank the police for
ensuring that those protests were able
to take place it's an event I think
overall that this country can be proud
of I'm sure all of us uh want to wish uh
King Charles III well at the beginning
of his new Reign and say God Save the
King
[Applause]